It’s the
biggest scandal in US history.
On August 8, 1974, Richard Milhouse Nixon
became the first-ever president to resign,
mere days before Congress could impeach him.
The cause of this epoch-shaking event was
the Watergate Scandal, an attempted wiretapping
of the Democratic National Election Headquarters
and its subsequent coverup.
Even now, after four decades of scandals as
varied as Iran-Contra, Monica Lewinsky, and
whatever the hell was happening in 2016, Watergate
remains the gold-standard of high crimes and
misdemeanours.
“-Gate” has even entered the lexicon as
a suffix denoting scandal.
But while most of us are aware of Watergate,
how much do we know about the man behind it
all?
Born into a blue collar family in 1913, Richard
Nixon was a natural political animal.
Throughout his House and Senate careers, he
earned a reputation as a formidable opponent.
First as Eisenhower’s VP, then as President
in his own right, he oversaw initiatives that
transformed America.
Yet the 37th President would wind up dynamiting
his own legacy in the most-dramatic way possible.
Flawed, paranoid, brilliant; this is the tale
of Richard Nixon, the most-controversial president.
The Glory of Poverty
As he would never tire of saying, the 37th
President came from a hard background.
Born on January 9, 1913, in Yorba Linda, California,
Richard Milhouse Nixon grew up not in a fancy-ass
mansion, but a modest home he shared with
four siblings.
His perpetually-angry father, Frank, owned
a service station and a small, failing citrus
farm that never brought in much more than
a handful of pennies.
As Nixon would later reminisce:
"We were poor, but the glory of it was we
didn't know it."
However, you could argue this statement was
not entirely accurate.
For his entire adult life, Nixon would privately
rail against those born with a silver spoon
in their mouths: the Kennedys, or the wealthy
New York Jews he perceived as enemies.
Young Nixon may well have been poor.
But he very much seemed to know it.
Still, this wasn’t the sort of grinding,
soul-sapping poverty that hollows you out.
Growing up, Nixon found time to read stacks
of books, run for class president, and engage
his Quaker mother in energetic debates.
It was in these good-natured arguments that
he got his first taste of politics.
The dawning of the 1920s brought a string
of bad news for the Nixon family.
First, the family citrus farm went under,
forcing them to leave their home and move
to nearby Whittier.
Then, Nixon’s youngest brother Arthur died
in 1925, aged only 7.
A few years later, his oldest brother, Harold,
also passed away; suffering a long, lingering
death from tuberculosis.
It was a traumatic time for the family.
But you wouldn’t know it from looking at
Nixon.
At Whittier High School, the boy was excelling,
eventually graduating second in his class.
He was offered a scholarship to Harvard but,
alas, the family was too poor to send him
away.
Instead, Nixon had to make do with a local
Quaker college.
Still, the boy applied himself, earning a
reputation as a debate champion; a great football
player; and a charismatic actor in the school’s
drama productions.
When he graduated in 1934, Nixon was so red
hot that Duke University’s law school practically
threw a scholarship at him.
By 1937, Nixon was a 24-year old qualified
lawyer with some of the best grades in the
whole damn state.
He should’ve been set for life.
But things weren’t so easy for a boy from
a hardscrabble background.
Every prestigious law firm Nixon applied to
turned him down.
Stung, Nixon slunk back to Whittier.
He moved in above his parents’ garage, got
a deadend job at a small law firm and contemplated
how unfair life was.
Here he was, a gifted boy with the grades
to match, forced to slum it because… why?
Because his parents didn’t have enough money?
But while returning to Whittier would leave
a bitter taste Nixon would never shake, it
did at least have one positive outcome.
In 1938, Nixon joined a local community theatre.
There, at a rehearsal on January 18, he met
Thelma Catherine Ryan.
Known to her friends as “Pat”, she was
glamorous, beguiling.
After driving her home that evening, the young
lawyer declared:
“I’d like to have a date with you.”
To which she replied:
“I’m busy.”
Not exactly a fairytale romance.
But Nixon persevered.
When he heard Pat enjoyed ice skating - a
sport he’d never tried - he spent weeks
forcing himself to learn how to skate, just
so he could “accidentally” meet her at
the rink.
Finally, after a year as just friends, Pat
caved.
She agreed to that date.
On June 21, 1940, Nixon and Pat were married.
Together, they agreed to keep chasing their
dreams, to keep being ambitious.
Two years later, they moved from California
to Washington, D.C, where Nixon got a job
in the Office of Price Administration.
It was 29-year old’s first foray into the
world of politics.
It certainly wouldn’t be his last.
Street Fighting Man
In the end, Nixon lasted less than a year
in the Office of Price Administration.
An FDR New Deal program, it was the embodiment
of big government, something that chilled
Nixon to his soul.
He quit in disgust.
But rather than return to practicing law,
he joined the Navy.
This was a pretty impressive thing to do.
As a Quaker, Nixon was exempt from serving
- something of a get out of jail free card
considering the massive bloody war going on.
But Nixon enlisted regardless, serving in
the Pacific.
Although he never saw combat, he still managed
to pick up two service stars before resigning
his commission in January, 1946.
Barely had Nixon swapped his starched, white
uniform for a dull gray suit than a group
of Republicans from his hometown approached
him with an interesting proposition.
Five term Democrat Jerry Voorhis was up for
reelection in California’s 12th District.
Despite being soft on Communism, no Republican
had ever been able to unseat him.
But with a war hero as their candidate, then
maybe… just maybe…
Throughout 1946, Nixon went for the election
with the same bloodymindedness he’d shown
pursuing Pat.
Despite his reputation, Voorhis’s actual
connections to Communism were non-existent.
So, Nixon just made them up.
At a town hall debate, Nixon flourished a
scrap of paper supposedly linking Voorhis
to a Communist-linked PAC.
Nevermind that Nixon was actually talking
about a completely different PAC.
Nevermind that Voorhis was against Communism.
In voters’ minds, the Democrat was now a
Red.
Come November, they voted for Nixon in droves.
It was Nixon’s first experience with negative
campaigning - the art of not making yourself
look good, but making your opponent look worse.
He was an goddamn genius at it.
After a short stint in the House - which included
the successful prosecution of Alger Hiss,
a State Department employee turned Soviet
stooge - Nixon ran for the Senate.
This time, his campaigning was so negative
it approached absolute zero.
Nixon slandered his opponent as "pink right
down to her underwear".
His staff handed out “pink sheets,” falsely
comparing her voting record to that of Communists.
As in 1946, it worked.
Nixon became Senator.
However, he also picked up something else
alongside his Senate seat.
Aghast at his negative campaign, the California
press branded Nixon “Tricky Dick.”
It was a nickname that would stick with him
for life.
But what did Dick Nixon care?
From a bright, blue collar kid spurned by
elites, he had gone on to become a Washington
insider.
And his meteoric rise wouldn’t stop there.
In 1952, Republican nominee Dwight D. Eisenhower
picked Tricky Dick to be his running mate,
hoping that Nixon’s California roots would
win him the West.
It was Nixon’s ticket to the big leagues.
It was also nearly his undoing.
That September, the New York Post splashed
a story of a secret Nixon slush fund using
campaign donations to support his lifestyle.
Although untrue, it nearly torpedoed Nixon’s
chances.
Eisenhower called him and basically said:
“Look, Dick.
Sort out this massive balls-up or I’ll find
a new VP.
Got it?”
Nixon got it.
On September 23, 1952, Richard Nixon went
on TV to explain himself.
It was the first-ever political speech televised
live, drawing a staggering 60 million viewers.
Before them all, Nixon laid bare his finances
in painful, pitiful detail, painting a picture
of a struggling, relatable man.
The speech was full of pathetic, human touches,
such as when Nixon confessed:
“Pat doesn't have a mink coat.
But she does have a respectable Republican
cloth coat, and I always tell her she would
look good in anything.”
But what made the speech famous was when Nixon
announced he had been given one political
gift: a cocker spaniel named Checkers that
his children loved.
And, damn it, they were gonna keep that dog.
Known as the Checkers Speech today, the live
broadcast saved Nixon’s career.
Eisenhower called him up and declared “you’re
my boy.”
That November 4, the Eisenhower-Nixon ticket
won in a landslide.
It now seemed that Dick Nixon’s rise was
unstoppable.
Rise, and Fall… and Rise
There’s an Eisenhower quote that brilliantly
sums up Nixon’s time as VP.
Asked by a reporter what policies his Veep
had contributed, Eisenhower wryly replied:
“If you give me a week, I might think of
one.”
But while Nixon wasn’t transforming the
nation as VP, he was still working hard on
his main project:
To make Richard Nixon look as much like a
future president as possible.
That meant doing stuff like going on a tour
of Venezuela, where he won praise for cooly
dealing with an anti-American mob.
It meant stuff like traveling to the USSR,
where he engaged Premier Nikita Khrushschev
in a spirited debate inside a model American
kitchen.
In this quest, Nixon was helped by Eisenhower’s
failing health.
Starting in 1955, Eisenhower suffered a series
of heart attacks that often left Nixon as
de-facto president.
Despite worries he’d use his temporary role
as a bully pulpit, Nixon won plaudits as a
sober, sensible leader.
So, when Eisenhower’s second term expired
and it became time to pick the next Republican
nominee, everyone was squarely behind Nixon.
With his experience, Nixon hoped the 1960
election would be a cakewalk, continuing his
unstoppable rise.
Unfortunately, the blue collar boy was about
to go slamming into the glass ceiling.
You all know the tale of the 1960 election.
How fresh-faced, vibrant John Kennedy completely
blew stuffy old Nixon out the water.
But while most people credit JFK’s media
nous and wise pick of Lyndon Johnson as his
running mate for his victory, Nixon saw it
another way.
As the presidency slipped from his grasp,
Nixon became convinced that the true culprit
wasn’t Kennedy’s charisma, or even the
recent recession.
It was Kennedy’s money.
As far as Nixon was concerned, this was just
another case of the elites screwing over the
working class boy.
That November, he felt he didn’t lose the
presidency so much as have it stolen from
him.
It was the end of Nixon’s rise… and the
start of his long fall.
His career in tatters, Nixon returned to California.
There, local Republicans convinced him to
run for governor.
Just two years after failing to become president,
Nixon lost California’s gubernatorial race
by a depressing margin.
In the wake of the defeat, Nixon called a
press conference, where he bitterly declared:
“You won't have Nixon to kick around anymore,
because, gentlemen, this is my last press
conference."
What followed was a period in the political
wilderness.
Being the political wilderness, it was way
more comfortable than the actual wilderness,
and saw Nixon become rich for the first time
from his law practice.
It also saw the former political streetfighter
refashion himself as an elder statesman, making
measured observations on the Vietnam War.
However, Nixon was still politically-minded
enough to campaign for Barry Goldwater at
the 1964 election.
Although Goldwater lost, Nixon’s support
made him a darling of the Republican right.
It was almost like Nixon was courting conservatives,
building himself a powerbase in case he ever
decided to run for president again.
It was a shrewd move.
As 1968 approached, the Republican party began
searching for its next standard-bearer.
The obvious choice was an electrifying rising
star from California; a former actor christened
the future of the party.
That actor’s name was Ronald Reagan, and
he’d go on to transform the GOP’s fortunes.
But not in 1968.
As Reagan’s popularity grew, Nixon crept
back out the shadows.
Began approaching prominent conservatives,
ensuring they lined up behind him.
By the time Reagan’s campaign really got
underway, the nomination had already been
sewn up.
That August, 1968, Nixon was unanimously declared
Republican nominee.
By now, the Democrats were in chaos.
Lyndon B. Johnson had refused to run; the
convention had seen riots; and frontrunner
Bobby Kennedy had been assassinated.
Against that kinda backdrop, what else could
possibly happen?
On November 5, 1968, Richard Nixon swept the
electoral college to win the presidency.
His popular vote share - 43% - was one of
the lowest in history, eaten away by third
party candidate George Wallace.
But a win was still a win.
Against all the odds, he’d shown them.
Shown those stuck up elites, those Kennedys,
those New York liberals.
The Nixon era had now begun…
...and Tricky Dick was certain it would go
down in history.
Do You Remember…
Your President Nixon?
Normally in a presidential Biographics, this
would be the point to talk you through their
term in office, hopefully with some jokes
thrown in.
But, since this video is only 26 minutes,
and we’ve still got a massive thing called
Watergate to discuss, we’re gonna have to
just give you the barest overview of the Nixon
presidency.
And that’s a shame, because there’s so
much to talk about.
Take school busing.
Although education had been desegregated under
Eisenhower, geographic separation meant most
schools were still mono-colored.
One solution was school busing, which involved
busing Black children into white schools.
Although Nixon was against the practice, a
Supreme Court ruling forced him to enforce
it.
Dick’s solution?
New Federalism.
At its heart, New Federalism was desegregation
- but done by local communities, rather than
the government.
Biracial committees were established across
the South, each charged with implementing
desegregation.
Rather than simply passing the buck, it actually
worked.
Between Nixon’s election and 1970, the number
of Black kids in racially-segregated schools
dropped from 70 percent to only 18 percent.
Then there’s the environment.
If you’re below a certain age, the words
“Republican president” plus “environment”
probably conjure images of guys in expensive
suits gleefully pouring gallons of oil onto
baby seals.
But not Nixon.
Tricky Dick was well aware that green issues
were a vote winner among moderate Democrats,
so he leaned into them.
It was on Nixon’s watch that the Environmental
Protection Agency was created, and the Clean
Air Act passed.
Another thing Dick Nixon supported was women’s
rights.
While Nixon’s environmentalism came mostly
from cynical vote-grabbing, his desire for
gender equality was mostly sincere.
Nixon directed the Federal government to launch
affirmative action on women’s rights, and
passed legislation like Title IX, forbidding
sex discrimination in education.
Then there was war.
It was Nixon who started both the War on Cancer,
the War on Drugs, plus the actual War in Cambodia
after he authorized US incursions.
That last one, by the way, led to one of the
most infamous non-Watergate moments of his
presidency.
On May 4, 1970, peaceful demonstrators gathered
at Kent State.
There, before hundreds of witnesses, the Ohio
National Guard shot dead four unarmed people,
and injured another nine.
Despite massive public outcry, the Nixon White
House didn’t prosecute any guardsmen.
The last major Nixon initiative we should
talk about is China.
In February, 1972, Nixon surprised the world
by going to visit the Middle Kingdom.
“Surprised” because, until that point,
China had been America’s boogeyman number
2, right behind the USSR.
But Nixon realized he could keep the USSR
in check by cozying up to Beijing.
Although the move was cynical, it’s now
seen as the moment Communist China started
opening up to the world.
So there you have it.
Four years of Nixon - four of the most dramatic
years in modern US history - condensed into
about 400 words.
And we still had to leave so much out; from
the Oil Crisis, to ending the draft, to the
Nixon Shock that ended Bretton-Woods and set
the stage for a decade of stagflation.
Still, at least you’re now aware there was
more to the Nixon presidency than merely scandal,
especially as we move towards the biggest
scandal of all.
It’s finally time to talk about Watergate.
Watergate - Part One
The Beastie Boys once sang “I’m-a set
it straight, this Watergate,” and that’s
exactly what I’m gonna do for you right
now.
Wish me luck, because it’s super complicated.
Although Nixon’s first term was outwardly
successful, behind the scenes, Tricky Dick’s
paranoia was increasing.
In February of 1971, the 37th President installed
a secret taping system in the White House,
one activated the moment anyone entered the
room.
But the real crazy started on June 13, 1971.
That was the day the New York Times published
the Pentagon Papers - top secret documents
laying bare American atrocities and incompetence
in Vietnam.
While the papers stopped with Lyndon Johnson’s
White House, Nixon was still outraged at the
leak.
It was from this outrage that the White House
Plumbers were formed.
A top-secret team, the Plumbers were there
to stop leaks through the use of spying, sabotage,
and break-ins.
Their first act was to break into the office
of the shrink who treated the Pentagon Papers’
leaker.
It wouldn’t be the last time the Plumbers
got involved in something shady.
OK, let’s fast forward a year now, to 1972.
Nixon is up for reelection, and his most-likely
opponent is the formidable Democratic Senator,
Edmund Muskie.
That spring, a bizarre string of problems
beset Muskie.
White voters in early states were harassed
by late night phone calls from rude people
who claimed they were Black supporters of
Muskie.
Others received letters on Muskie stationary
that spewed absurd conspiracy theories about
his primary opponents.
Yep, it was Nixon, back to his old negative
campaigning.
But now he had help from both the Plumbers,
and the Campaign to Reelect the President
- pleasingly abbreviated to CREEP.
And CREEP would stop at nothing to fulfil
their mission.
By April, the pressure had torpedoed Muskie’s
run, but still the Plumbers were at it.
At 2a.m. on June 17, 1972, they broke into
Democrat Party HQ in the Watergate Office
Building, intending to bug the place.
Instead, they got caught by a security guard.
Within two days, the Washington Post was reporting
that one of the burglars was a salaried member
of CREEP, but Nixon assumed it would blow
over.
He’s actually on tape declaring the story
will die, and saying
“Who the hell's going to keep it alive?”
The two-name answer?
Bob Woodward and Carl Bernstein.
All through that hot summer, the Post reporters
published articles covering CREEP’s dirty
tricks, and linking a Nixon check for $28,000
to one of the Watergate burglars.
But no-one was paying any attention.
Behind the scenes, Nixon was ordering the
CIA to interfere with the FBI’s Watergate
investigation.
Out in the open, the Democrats had nominated
leftwing populist George McGovern as their
candidate, and Nixon was making mincemeat
out of him.
Despite the steady trickle of Watergate stories,
Nixon crushed McGovern in ‘72, winning one
of the biggest landslides in US history.
Seriously, the only comparable victories are
FDR in ‘36 and Reagan in ‘84.
But while the voters had agreed to re-insert
Dick into the White House for a second term,
the wheels were already coming off the presidency.
Just days before Nixon’s inauguration, the
seven men involved in the Watergate break-in
went on trial.
Perhaps Nixon expected them to stay loyal
to him.
If so, his trust was misplaced.
Over the next few months, these seven men
would nearly all choose saving their own skins
over saving Nixon.
Tricky Dick couldn’t see it yet, but his
presidency was already doomed.
The Fall
Richard Nixon’s second term is a little
like reading Shakespearean tragedy reimagined
as depressing farce.
Barely was Nixon back in the Oval Office than
the walls started closing in.
On February 7, the Democrat-controlled Senate
passed Resolution 60, establishing the Watergate
Hearings.
Initially, this didn’t bother Nixon much.
He went on TV to assure viewers he was blameless,
that the fault lay with some rouge aides.
Most people believed him.
But then May rolled around and things started
to unravel.
On the 18th, special prosecutor Archibald
Cox was appointed.
Shortly thereafter, the secret White House
taping system was discovered.
Not unreasonably, Cox was all like:
“Oh, so you’ve been recording your conversations
this entire time?
Mind if I have a listen?”
To which Nixon was all like:
“Err.
No.
But I will tell you what’s on the tapes:
they definitely, definitely prove I’m innocent!”
As the clamour grew to release the tapes,
Nixon’s paranoia reached new heights.
In his head, it was everything he’d ever
feared: shadowy elites teaming up with a Jewish
reporter to screw over poor, blue collar Dick
Nixon.
Convinced he had enemies everywhere, the 37th
President lashed out in the most self-destructive
way possible.
The Saturday Night Massacre on October 20,
1973, was a turning point in the scandal.
In quick succession, Nixon fired both his
Attorney General and Deputy Attorney General
for refusing to fire Archibald Cox, before
his Solicitor General agreed to carry out
the order.
Half an hour later, Nixon ordered the FBI
to seal off Cox’s offices.
It was supposed to kill the investigation
through force.
Instead, it created outrage.
In the House, impeachment charges were filed.
Fellow Republicans began to speak out against
their president.
Chastised, Nixon was forced to hire a new
special prosecutor, Leon Jaworski.
By now, it was clear the president had something
to hide.
The rest of the story plays out with painful
inevitability.
There’s the infamous “I’m not a crook
speech” in November, 1973.
The March, 1974 indictment of seven Nixon
aides by a Grand Jury.
There’s the subpoena for the White House
tapes.
The Supreme Court battle that ruled against
Nixon on July 24, forcing him to release them.
After that, it was all over.
On August 5, 1974, the first transcripts of
the tapes appeared in the media.
They included Nixon directing the CIA to interfere
with the FBI’s investigation.
The press dubbed this recording “the Smoking
Gun”.
The strangest thing about Watergate in hindsight
is that Nixon really didn’t have anything
to do with the break-in.
CREEP and the Plumbers really had gone rouge,
and Nixon could’ve probably weathered that
smaller scandal.
Instead, he chose to cover it up.
And that was a much bigger deal.
Following the release of the transcripts,
Congress moved to impeach Nixon.
It’s almost certain the votes were there
to remove him from office.
But Nixon never gave them the chance.
On August 8, 1974, Richard Nixon announced
his resignation - the only president in history
to do so.
At noon the next day, he and his family left
by helicopter.
As they departed, Nixon turned, grinned, and
flashed a V sign for “victory”.
And so ended Dick Nixon’s presidency.
Less than a month later, on September 8, new
president Gerald Ford issued a blanket pardon
for any crimes Richard Nixon may have committed
while in office.
It was a hugely unpopular move, and one that
likely handed the Democrats the White House
in 1976, but there was nothing anyone could
do.
Dick Nixon was now, and would always be, a
free man.
The only question now was what to do with
all this unexpected freedom.
The End of All That
That’s not a huge amount to say about Nixon’s
life after the White House.
He and Pat moved back to California, settled
in San Clemente.
At first, the disgraced president kept his
head low, but legal fights had so sapped his
bank account that he returned to public life
just to get his money back.
And so we got the unedifying spectacle of
the Frost-Nixon interviews, which earned Nixon
$600,000; and the publication of his memoirs,
which netted him $2m.
Yet even though Nixon remained a hugely divisive
figure with the public, those on Capitol Hill
could never quite let go of him.
Across the next fifteen years, Presidents
Jimmy Carter, Ronald Reagan, and George H.W.
Bush all came to consult with Tricky Dick,
searching out his expertise in foreign policy.
By 1990, the image of Nixon as an elder statesman
had so entered the political class that three
ex-Presidents came to the opening of his library.
In a weird way, this was everything Nixon
had ever dreamed of.
Here he was, a man who had committed high
crimes and misdemeanours, yet had not only
never faced justice; but was now being publicly
honored.
Does that sound like a blue collar kid from
the sticks… or like a member of the privileged
elite?
Richard Nixon finally died on April 22, 1994.
At his funeral, President Bill Clinton gave
a stirring eulogy that ended with the words:
“May the day of judging President Nixon
on anything less than his entire life and
career come to a close.”
The political rehabilitation of Richard Nixon
was now so total that Watergate was seemingly
forgotten.
But the story doesn’t end there.
Today, the Watergate scandal is older than…
well, me for starters; plus major stuff like
Star Wars, the Iranian Revolution, and entire
countries like Angola, Slovakia, or Mozambique.
In short, it’s history.
Something that happened in the dim and distant
past.
Yet, somehow, we still remember it.
In a world where even major political scandals
like Iran-Contra or the Pentagon Papers have
slipped from the public’s mind, that’s
saying something.
For whatever reason, Watergate has become
only more-notorious.
It’s now the gold standard of scandal.
No matter how hard the political class may
have tried, it will always stain Nixon’s
name,
And yet, there’s no denying there was more
to the 37th President than a single scandal.
Richard Nixon a complex, flawed, and brilliant
man.
He was insecure and bullying; but also a man
who understood the pain of being an outsider.
An ordinary man who really thought he could
change his country for the better.
Too often in history and politics, we like
to paint simple narratives.
This man is a monster, this man is a saint,
blah, blah, blah…
But real life is never so simple, and men
like Nixon are never simply caricatures, cartoon
villains there to be laughed at.
They’re human beings who really hurt, really
care… and sometimes even manage to do some
good.
Richard Nixon may be long gone now, but the
lessons we learned from his presidency should
stay with us forever.
It’s easy to hate such a man.
It takes real guts to try to understand him.